les etats-unis et leurs alliés ne sont
pas des partenaires fiables
la russie ne peut pas dépendre de leurs
moeurs a déclaré le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov pour lui
la diplomatie américaine consiste à
menacer le monde et sa politique à
l'égard de la russie mène à une impasse
absolue je vous propose d'écouter un
représentant spécial est nommé pour
mettre fin au projet nord stream 2 il va
aller ici et là menacer tout le monde
voilà à quoi ressemble cette diplomatie
qui n'est pas la diplomatie de la
canonnière mais une diplomatie qui
pillent de nouveaux instruments de
sanctions mais cette politique suscite
de plus en plus de critiques aux états
unis
je pense que même une structure aussi
pro ashington que l'omg atlantic council
publié à l'heure actuelle des textes
critiques de la politique américaine à
l'égard de la russie ligne sochaux
[Musique]
politique qui mène à une impasse absolue
qui est même peut être stupide car elle
n'apporte aucun résultat pour ce qui est
des objectifs déclarés au moment où ces
sanctions ont été introduits masse et
sergueï lavrov a également évoqué la
problématique du traité sur le ciel
ouvert pour lui les états unis ne
veulent pas de maîtrise des armements
écoutez nous savons avec certitude qu'au
cours de tous ces mois après leur
annonce du retrait du traité
les américains ont convaincu leurs
alliés de promettre de leur transmettre
ces données discrètement en cachette
c'est pourquoi nous avons eu besoin de
garanties supplémentaires
on ne nous les a pas donné c'est pour ça
que nous avons déclaré le début de la
préparation à la procédure de retrait de
ce traité si le retour au traité devait
saper les positions américaines en
matière de maîtrise des armements
cela veut dire que les états unis ne
veulent pas de maîtrise des armements je
rappelle que selon les informations de
bloomberg
les etats unis s'apprêtent à introduire
de nouvelles sanctions à l'égard de la
russie ainsi que renvoyer plusieurs
diplomates russes